[Música]
los guías turísticos la mencionan poco
porque en el mundo de la joyería la
discreción es la palabra clave durante
un siglo la comuna de santa monja en el
departamento de ser fue la capital de
los brazaletes de oro
ese pasado ya quedó atrás jean-claude
sur acá lo conoce bien
durante los años 70 se instaló en esta
ciudad que aún se seguía llamando la
pequeña parís
en esa época santa más era el dorado
porque había trabajo había mucha en fin
una actividad económica comercial muy
fuerte había tiendas de lujo zapatos de
lujo ropa de lujo de hecho muchos
clientes venían desde burgueses a
comprar a santa marta salta más
fabricaba cuatro toneladas de joyas de
uno al año
hasta los años 80 los joyeros desanta
monfá bree cavan kilómetros de
brazaletes y collares de oro
en ese momento la ciudad tenía cerca de
500 trabajadores que dedicaban las
jornadas a su especialidad
la cadena tejida en oro de 18 quilates
el joyero tiene un recuerdo divertido de
esa época
el famoso brazalete americano si un ama
de casa de más de 50 años en esa época
no tenía un brazalete como éste era que
no había tenido éxito en la vida o que
el marido no había tenido éxito
trabajar el oro se ha vuelto una
actividad poco frecuente en santa a 46
euros el gramo el metal precioso se
vende cada vez menos hoy en día el
joyero pasa más tiempo comprando el euro
a sus clientes que fabricando joyas con
él
si fabricó cuando tengo pedidos
especiales
pero cada vez hago menos cada vez menos
porque bueno el oro es demasiado caro y
por ser demasiado caro ya no está de
moda
además aunque tengo algunos clientes
parisinos no estamos en una región donde
se pueda gastar demasiado dinero mucho
menos en joyas
a partir de los años 80 el precio del
oro se dispara
las joyas en oro se vuelven demasiado
caras y los joyeros de santa quiebran
uno tras otro
en el 2000 la municipalidad trata de
salvar la industria invierte 9 millones
de euros para construir esta pirámide la
ciudad de oro
el objetivo salvar los oficios
artísticos y los últimos joyeros
pero
en realidad eran talleres que estaban
reservados para los profesionales
a veces venían personas pero realmente
no era una tienda panigutti que oferta
tres artesanos se instalan allí se
organizan exposiciones pero los joyeros
se resisten a instalarse cerca de la
pirámide el proyecto de crear un pueblo
del oro fracasa
ya
que la joyería tiene un lado muy
discreto casi secreto
así que claro reunir en un solo punto
cientos de kilos de oro no es en efecto
es una apuesta arriesgada
en 2017 unos ladrones le dan la razón a
los joyeros
se roban una gran parte de la colección
para la ciudad de oro es el golpe de
gracia se transforma de manera
definitiva en un centro de convenciones
hoy en día si bien sólo quedan tres
empresas especializadas en joyería de
lujo en santa montt
la destreza se sigue enseñando en el
liceo profesional de jong enoh
si lo miras así vas a tener la impresión
de ver mejor pero te desviará a la
izquierda oa la derecha y no tendrás
algo preciso creado en 1968 este liceo
profesional dedicado al aprendizaje de
la joyería y de los oficios artísticos
es la institución más grande de europa
en este sector
angelina tiene tan solo 15 años es hija
de joyeros y decidió aprender este
oficio por la precisión y la exigencia
con una avispa con concesión al grifo
cuando uno no lo logra o comienza a
desesperarse hay que controlarse por
ejemplo para esta pieza utilizamos
pedazos de metal tenemos un depósito
donde hay muchos pedazos a partir de
piezas planas había que doblar las y
cerró charlas para darles forma
esto te hace sentir orgullosa sí bueno
porque me costó bastante trabajo pero sí
no todos los graduados serán artesanos
algunos trabajarán en la industria
armamentística donde son necesarias las
habilidades de los joyeros
lo cierto es que casi todos los 290
jóvenes encontrarán un trabajo
y
no solo transmitimos gestos tratamos de
transmitirles una sensibilidad y para
adquirir esta sensibilidad en la
profesión manual hay que estar dentro
hay que estar en contacto
en realidad es una historia de amor
la historia de amor entre santa manojo y
los oficios artísticos no terminó con el
cierre de las joyerías locales se
mantiene a través de las nuevas
generaciones que continúan formándose
aquí en el arte de trabajar el oro
[Música]